what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone do we just become best friends
yep
hello everybody i swear this intro does
not get boring for me
it's really fun to listen to it is yeah
we just look at each other the entire
time we're in it
we've listened to it probably a hundred
times and so it doesn't get old it
doesn't get old
welcome back if you guys are still here
thank you
if you're leaving you're missing out but
i wanted to get into today because we
have a really really fun episode we have
two amazing bachelor contestants
probably our personal favorites
on the show yeah we have mike johnson
and danny demi
brunette burnett yeah and they are
super cool it's gonna be totally
different episodes we have mike talking
about his book we have demi probably
we're gonna talk about confidence we're
gonna talk about
dating we'll see actually i'm not really
sure what to expect from her because
she's
pretty out there fun girl so no it's
it's very exciting we thought we'd kick
off this episode
with a little wax and weigh in action um
you want to get at it i feel like i
actually don't have a high of my week i
just have two lows of my week
um well okay sophie and i have been
talking a lot about
tick tock and i know we discussed tick
tock with our producer well
and well are you on tick tock by the way
i'm not on tick tock good i still don't
really get it
and it's the thing that is now really
setting me apart as an older person i
was gonna say
what age are you too old to be on tick
tock
oh i don't know because there's a lot of
celebrities on tick tock and they do it
well
and they're yeah but they're getting
paid so imagine if you're just not
getting paid you're just on the app for
enjoyment 35. oh so i'm good oh you're
great
oh it's made for you guys but no i'm 24.
and
i feel poor i hate that i'm on it but i
love it
no no i was saying it's the scene the
other night that i feel like
i'm getting way too addicted to this
thing because i'll be on it for
an hour and not even really realize it
before bed and then i can't fall asleep
because i was on my phone too often yeah
and there's also like the my favorite
part about tick tock is all of the
stupid trends they're not stupid because
i love them they're not stupid i love
these especially dumb trends
but but no because sistine fully
immerses herself
into these okay you know the new well
maybe i don't know when we release this
it won't be a new trend anymore but
there's a new
[ __ ] trend to that song and everyone's
doing that dance
do you know what i'm talking about i
also say that that is like isn't that an
offensive term for italian people
is it is it yeah oh and why has anyone
brought that up
i don't know oh what does that even mean
though it's like i don't think anybody
really is offended by it but that was
like an old like 1920s thing well i
might be offended by it i'm a little
we're a little italian
so there's this [ __ ] dance that
everyone's doing where i don't even know
why it's on tick tock it is very
x-rated there are children on this app
but basically
you twerk you do the splits you do the
whole thing and if i could show you guys
my body i'm showing the camera
i'm covered in bruises bruises bruises
from this dumb dance she's been
practicing the stance folks for
three days straight but you know what's
annoying that i've seen
when people do this dance is that they
are so good at it
yeah they are so these 17 18 year olds
are dropping it low hitting the splits
twerking in this it's ridiculous and i
thought why has no one put out
a bad version of this dance you know
what i mean yeah like
should i people that sustain you can't
touch your toes but that doesn't mean
you can't do the splits or try to
yeah no i can't touch my toes you know
what if this video
gets only five likes i'll do it you
don't have to twist my arm
we're just going for five likes can i
tell you another trend that i've been
obsessed with
what it's the the that's actually that's
what it's called it's the blank for me
trend what is
you know when people so basically people
will say to
let's just say if i said sistine it's
the long limbs for me
and so it's supposed to be a roast yeah
so basically you say
what ticks you off about the other
person right should we do it
oh [ __ ] okay i'm kind of nervous
okay okay well we are going to do it to
each other we just decided this
okay you are going to decide who did it
better
or who roasted the other one better
we're going to fight is either like a
scoring system or is it just a win or
lose
just a win or lose you're going to hear
our roasts just say who got the better
the roast yeah who got served the most
exactly yeah
we're i think we just do five each
sophia do you want to start i don't even
know what i'm gonna say you start
all right it's the big feet for me
it's the ho hoops for me it's the over
dyed hair for me
it's the long witch nails for me
it's the sneezes that sound like rocket
ships taking off for me
literally every time it's the migraines
for me
it's the wearing crop tops meant for
toddlers for me
it's the singing for me it's the
befriending all your exes for me
it's the playing games for me because i
win all those games
[ __ ] i want to keep going i know she
i'm not that not like he did
did we just keep going you're scaring me
i know one
oh it's the studying how to play
football so you can act like one of the
boys
for me i actually like football first of
all
um it's the
mean comments followed by it's just a
joke for me
it's the pretty hair for me
it's the sexy body for me it's the good
smile for me
it's the big heart for me it's the nice
boobs for me
it's the long legs for me all right okay
i think we're good
to a compliment now i have to say now
it's like you both win because it got
nice
oh i can make it mean but if we wanted
to go back to mean yeah
i do think that sophia's was a little
more savage also you said she had long
witch nails and she does not currently
have long i don't know
i don't they're actually pretty it's the
nail biting for me
i actually am very healthy i take a lot
of collagen it's by nail biting for me
i don't nail bite i just click my oh my
god that was so much
fun you know i want to go harder though
i don't want to go harder
okay fine i i hope you guys tried this
challenge with your friends record it
see their reactions because it's
definitely going to be um
either world war three or something you
guys can laugh about all right well i
think this is a good
time to just go right into the episode
we're going to bring on demi brunette
who is probably the most savage
contestant i've ever seen
on the bachelor we are so excited we're
going to talk about
confidence her experience on it we're
going to get a little juicy hopefully
she'll give us some
some tea first we are going to talk to
mike johnson
sophia and i love to have a good time
and
although we love our tequila the
consequences the following day
always makes us reconsider our love for
them i think we can all agree on one
thing
hangovers are the worst not only are you
sluggish
anxious and nauseous your entire day is
thrown off
until we met our saving grace cbd talks
this zero thc
product not only reduces those brain
fogs and pain it can help you feel
calmer relieves nausea and helps your
body get rid of toxins
by only taking one to two capsules this
product has all-natural
antioxidants electrolytes and the detox
agents to help you feel better and help
your body recover faster
so we have a special 20 off discount for
you yes unwax listeners go to
shop.getcbdtalks.com
that's shop.get
and use code unwaxed at checkout they
offer a 30 money back
guarantee so you have nothing to lose by
trying it out
again go to shop.getcbdtalks.com and use
code
unwaxed for 20 off you can also find
them on instagram
at cbd talks remedy let us know what you
think
all right this handsome 32 year old may
be big in hype but also in his
heart you may recognize him from hannah
brown's season of the bachelor
but he will soon be known as
best-selling author we have
mike johnson there we go
there we go love it love you loved it
thank you thank you we actually just
wanted to jump
right in and talk about your book
because we were stoked to even hear that
you had one coming out it's october 2nd
right
yes world smile day october 2nd amazing
i love that
so it's called making the love you want
and basically
we're taking a quad out it's the guide
to leveling up our lives from the inside
out
through the practice of self-love so you
know tell us a little bit
tell us a little bit about what inspired
you to write this book
well can i can i ask you guys a question
in regards to that sure
making the love you want what do you
think when you hear that i
think about personally your self-love i
do think about
when you love yourself everything else
falls into place around you with your
relationships
your family your friends um work
hmm definitely you really
put us on the spot here now that i'm
thinking i mean
no it's good now i'm really reflecting
right now i think making the love i want
is i'm
basically putting out what i want for
myself
so if i attract you know
a negative person knowing that they
won't better my life in any way then
that's
the love i'm gonna give receive so yeah
i think you put out what you get in
i love that both of them both of you
guys are right like so this book isn't
about
relationships in the sense of if if one
of y'all were to date somebody right
it's about all relationships within your
life whether it's a
a personal relationship whether it's a
working relationship whether it's uh
within yourself
and how to grow within self so therefore
you could be better and reflect that
upon other people
right right i believe that self-love
literally starts within us
it's for your guys podcast right for you
ought to be the number one podcast in
the game
you have to believe in yourself and love
yourself enough to know that you can
make it happen
you know and so that's what self love is
all about it starts with itself in my
god my book
is actually a guide on how to obtain
that how to obtain what the two of you
have how to obtain what i have
but then also i want people to know that
just because someone may have it doesn't
mean that they always have it this is a
journey that
we all stumble know
it's something that i personally use so
that i can go back and forth on when i
stumble
right and i i actually also noticed in
the book you
do make it a point to take action with
everything so you know that
when you want to gain self-love it's not
just reading something and then trying
it out in the world you actually have to
put action
into it and i really appreciated that
you made people in your book
take a look in the mirror read some
mantras and really put this into their
day-to-day life i mean what made you
get to that point or decide to put that
in your book
i didn't hear you did you use that as
well like did you use all these things
that you put in your book with the
actions
and doing it day to day no no definitely
i create i created them based off of the
one of the biggest depressions that i've
been through personally in my life and
so these are things that i've done
in order to in order to be at this point
and i'm nowhere near where i will be but
i remember the first time i got out of
my depression
i was around people and i had to leave
the room and almost threw up
because i was just i hyperventilated
because i wasn't around
people for about 11 months you know and
so
in that month process these are the
the guidelines within my book are the
exact things that i've done
to help me get to where i am at right
and this book
isn't about me solely solely it is i do
have things in the book that i talk
about
that i still have to have a conversation
with my mom you know right
she's not gonna be uh the happiest but
she's going to love me no matter what
because i'll talk about
some of the crazy stupid illegal things
that i've done in life yeah
sort of piggybacking so we'll get into
your family because i want to ask all
about about
you know your mom and growing up in a
woman household because we love that we
have all women in our household too
but sort of going off of you were just
talking about how you had a difficult
period in your life
that you're still am i correct still
sort of going through a coming
overcoming
no i'm good now you're good now okay so
in the book you were very honest about
you know you got into fights a lot
you would you know go to fast food
restaurants and throw a package of
ketchup you said and
taunt people to fight you so during this
period in your life was there
a moment where you sort of just wanted
was there a switch that sort of went off
in your brain that you said this is no
longer what i want to do
what was that moment like yeah so i went
through what's called a disassociative
disorder i
was diagnosed with having dissociative
disorder
which basically means that it happens a
lot with people with trauma that have
gone through
severe trauma and literally the only day
i snapped out of it one day i was
watching like some music video on mtv or
whatever
and i learned in that very moment when i
snapped out that
for me personally if i'm not progressing
in life
if i'm not doing the best that i know
how to be which is the best mike johnson
there is the best version
then i will get into a depressed state
of mind i knew that i was being a
follower
and that's for damn sure is not what i
am um
and so that is one reason why i got into
that state of mind
and it was just more like
stop being a victim you know right i had
i had a
and i hate to say it so bluntly i played
more eloquently in my book but i had to
stop being a victim
i had to be vulnerable i think that
vulnerability creates bridges you know
and allows us to have a connection with
other people renee bailey
brene brown my apologies right and
for me it was just more like i would say
the more gangster terminology
the only easy day was yesterday and i
had to stop being a little [ __ ]
quite honestly i love that you overcame
that victim mentality
because i sometimes find myself throwing
a pity party and
and you know so that's really cool yeah
sometimes it's good and i really admire
when you said you're much more
vulnerable in the book and that is
a huge strength to have i mean being
vulnerable and exposing yourself and
really talking about all the harder
times in life it does
bring back memories even if you're doing
it for everybody else to really
gain something from it it does take a
lot of strength and patience and
kindness with yourself what was probably
the hardest yeah i
gave you a lot of credit to that what
was probably one of the hardest things
about
going back to that time and thinking
about because right now i can see you're
a very confident guy
or the way you come off is very
confident you're always smiling and
you're really kind to everybody around
you so when you had to write those
darker times in the book what was
how how was it getting back to that
mindset did you ever feel a little bit
more down when you were doing it or
was it pretty easy to be just naturally
open about everything that happened
no it damn sure it wasn't easy i'm not
gonna lie about it never will
i lie about that right um i call it
emotional homework
that's how i call it because i was you
know after i wrote the book
i sent it off to my editor my editor is
like no i need you to go deeper right
wow and i'm like damn i'm going pretty
deep and she's like no i need to go
deeper
so for me it was the way i did it was
get a bottle of wine i just talk
audio and then you know from there i
transcribe it and then i
write it out it was it's therapy
yeah truly there because when you're by
yourself
you don't at that very moment you don't
think that the world is going to read it
this is for you i encourage everyone to
do it actually it's
i mean speaking about the book that's
one of the exercises in the book i
encourage everyone to write down what
their definition of self-love is
themselves right
definitely and so for me
it was my it was therapy for me it was
i'm not gonna say scary but it was it's
like damn i'm really about to say this
yeah it's like the journal to your heart
you're really exposing 100 of who you
are
and i really loved reading about your
family and your mom and your grandma you
talked so much about them and i loved
reading about it
so you were raised by all women correct
yes so i love that but how was having to
be
the male figure of the family was that a
lot of pressure for you
uh no pressure is pressure isn't too
hard it was more so
i learned an early age that i'm never
going to win an argument against a woman
that's for damn sure absolutely you
can't you can tell my dad doesn't get
one word
in the house at all at all times i
learned that at an early age
but as far as like being the man of the
house i had to so meanwhile
we me my sister would do chores she
would do chores one week i'll do chores
for another week and i swear my mom was
harder on me probably because i'm the
oldest and the male
of the house and so i did all the quote
unquote man short was like going on a
roof
cutting down trees you know doing things
of that nature but then i also did
the quote unquote old-school female
chores of like washing the dishes
uh you know cleaning the bathroom but
then also
i worked two jobs always up until i went
to the military
and i was trying to bring home some
money as well and it wasn't hard it was
more so like
teaching me about life how to be an
independent man i talked to my book that
when i moved out my mom had talked to me
for three months and
my whole thing was mom that's your fault
you taught me how to you know
i gotta ask she didn't talk to you for
three months because
you're her baby and she just wanted you
home yeah my mom would be tripping
sometimes i love it
we're in the same predicament my friends
oh my god
i'm suffocating let's call the parents
out like y'all y'all did a great job so
allow us to thrive
let us know on a lighter note with your
mom and being raised with your sister
um was there ever a time that you had to
bring a girl
home that you were into and you're
introducing the family how was that
experience because i know for us on our
end when we bring a guy home with like
all girl household and my dad it gets
kind of chaotic if one person in the
family doesn't like the guy then no one
we're never going to see this guy again
are there harsh critics
hold up is your siblings are y'all all
just girls
so it's the three sisters and i um or
two sisters and i and then my mom and we
have
our dad female dogs even our dogs our
cats oh my god
yeah he feels bad for himself he's he's
throwing a pity party for himself every
day let me tell you
oh my god prayers to him oh yes
but how was that experience yeah what's
it like to bring women home to all girls
when you're
about to go on a date no so my mom she
cool now like i'm a girl
i'd say like this but i'm a grown ass
man now so she can't really
say anything about it you know when i
was
with that being said i've only brought
one woman home since i was 21 years old
wow
and the reason is because she said my
mom gangster sometimes
she was like don't bring another woman
home unless you see yourself marrying
her and the reason for that was because
she didn't want to like
become attached to a woman right like
two years later
i'm like no i'm done with her right and
so i'm very respectful of that because i
really want
whoever i you know end up with i want
her to be
like a daughter a lot of my mom you know
of course i want her to be like a sister
to my sister and so i don't want
the woman in my life getting attached
right to someone that
i don't see for a future you know but
i'll tell you this story
i went to like a lot of proms and
there's
one problem i went to was mine i almost
said her name
i brought her home come on excuse me i
almost said her name
i almost said it and um my mom was like
yo she has to come to church with us
and i'm like okay mom and so i brought
her to church my mom asked this girl one
question this girl said the dumbest
answer ever
my mom was like so like what do you want
to do when you grow up
that's a fair question right yeah of
course that's fair this girl said
mind you we're in high school i was
about to go to prom right this
young lady said i want to marry a nfl
player
oh she blew it i was like how did you
just in the fourth quarter 10 yards to
go she blew it
and she i was like come on like that was
she could have said
anything else honestly if you could have
answered any more shallow then
not yeah that was i mean you could just
fake it just say you're a veterinarian
anything else but i want to date a
nfl player oof yeah i was like come on
so did your mom give you [ __ ] after that
oh yeah my mom said she looked like a
rat
that's what we love an honor together we
love an honest mom
so did you think uh when you were
growing up did you ever think that you
were going to be an author
no never i honestly didn't think i would
even graduate high school
yeah yeah that's that's something most
people probably wouldn't even think
about but
yeah i didn't think i was going to
graduate high school let alone to write
a book to write a book that
is not a reality tv personality book
it's a
a full-length book right it's it's
beautiful
quite honestly i never thought it would
happen you know i actually almost think
that's better because you're really
doing it at a place
where it's very vulnerable and it's
yourself and it's not forced
and you're really just showing who you
are and showing your life lessons that
people can take that actually can gain
something from you you're not trained
professionally in this but i actually
think
that more people can relate to you on
that end i appreciate that
so i'm sorry sorry you go ahead
no i'm just saying that's one of the
cool things about i'm independent
and so therefore no one said put this in
a book put that in the book it's like
i'mma write in a way that's gonna be
authentic
and help my readers out the absolute
most absolutely
if your high school self could see what
mike johnson did today what do you think
he would say
damn bro you doing it hey there we go
so um i have a question since you
brought up the reality thing
not me so we're gonna talk about it for
a second
yeah yeah let's try to find a smooth
segway into it
so uh you're a handsome man
from what you've told us you've been
raised really well you served in the air
force
you seem like the cream of the crop
okay so why join a dating show that ends
in marriage
great question great question so
i think i look better in person by the
way these cameras are not doing it for
me no
i say that too by the way i hate photos
but uh
i'm picky let's be 100 about it right
i'm i'm extremely picky
but then outside of that like i
definitely dated women in san antonio
dated women around the world i i've been
on day naps
and like i wasn't finding my lady and so
my homeboy was like try this you know it
was another opportunity and
i'm not one to shy away from pretty much
nothing so
i was like we'll see what happens did
you learn now would i have
married that individual right then and
there no i probably would do like uh
jojo fletcher right uh jordan rogers i
would have like you know
kept dating for a bit more yeah yeah
did you learn anything from being in the
air force and then also being raised by
your
like all-girl household to going into a
reality show because i know
you go from having to court a woman in
front of i mean
millions of people and then also living
in a household full of men and it kind
of seems
almost a little bit similar in a way
that you could probably get some
perspective from each side
no definitely i learned a lot beautiful
question i appreciate it
i was just watching the first episode
last night
and i remember i saw one of the guys say
this is like the most stressful thing
i've ever been through
and i laughed my ass off right because
to me it's like bro we on a damn tv show
there's no there's no danger around us
whatsoever like
i've been shot at in the civilian life
and as well as in the military life and
so
to me i think the military taught me how
to handle
stress how to handle alpha males and how
to
ultimately do what i need to do right
and focus in
and then growing up in an all-women
household i know how to i know
how to pick and choose my battles right
and i know how to
i believe i know how to treat a woman
extremely well
but then with that being said on the tv
show that i was on
i'm definitely going to put somebody in
check that is needing to be put in check
of course like when one of the guys
would act stupid i'm like bro i'm here
for the right reasons how many take your
ass home
of course hey you got to do that um but
what i liked about reading your book is
when i initially got it i thought it was
going to be mike johnson
ex-bachelor contestant writing a book
about
finding love on the show but it wasn't
that at all to my surprise it really
wasn't
and it was extremely beautiful and
reflective
and uh again it's all about self-love
and accepting the love you think you
deserve
so mike what type of love do you think
you deserve
well i just gotta say thank you so much
man it's like this is my book it's my
baby and like for you to say that means
the world to me
no of course i think that in a lot of
things in life even sophie and i can
relate
it's really hard to separate for us it's
like we're constantly under the shadow
of our dad so it's hard to separate and
make a name for ourselves so i see what
you're doing
and you're executing it beautifully but
yeah i would love to know
what type of level you think you deserve
like i'm not going to deviate from the
question
yeah so like i'm not letting it go the
type of love that i deserve
i want they say that marriage isn't for
you right or love isn't for you and what
they mean by that is
if i'm in a relationship with you my
whole thing should be to make
you as happy as possible right and if
two people do that together then you're
gonna have a wonderful love
and that's how i truly look at it my job
in a relationship is to make my girl
feel like she's the baddest
she's the most confident she can do
anything she wants to do
uh she can tell me anything whether it's
hard or not
and i want that same in return that's
great
i'm big on communication like you need
to tell me like what's up like tell me
all the stuff that's good
but all the stuff that's hard right
because shame
is something that causes disconnection
you know and i don't want my girl to
ever feel like she cannot tell me
something
i love that but uh upon
further stalking you on wikipedia and
such
i read that you are capricorn
so i did some further investigation
capricorn men what are they about
and mike i don't know i don't know
apparently
you're the bad boy when it comes to love
capricorn men here this is what it said
exactly
called out it said capricorn men are
are labeled as bad boys although
incredibly sexy
they will whine and dine you they
probably have their own place to live
and will pick up the bill
it sounds pretty good to me i know i
don't know about that is this wikipedia
it is an official legitimate astrology
website
an official astrology website i'm i'm
definitely wanting to pick up the bill
i got my own place well i'm about to
move in with one of the dudes from the
show
but i got my own place and uh
no i'm i'm i'm pretty damn great when it
comes to all right so there you go we've
just
debunked that myth
so i actually won that i tried i
actually wanted to ask you going back to
your book
um what are small things that you do day
to day that make you happy because i
feel like a lot of people
to get some um some inspiration or
quotes from you what would things that
you do that they can
probably pick up that you do day to day
that really make you feel better that
make you feel confident
i uh i get butt naked put on my favorite
music get in front of the mirror and i
dance with your roommate
no i live by myself
that's ending when he moves looking at
your windows right now you got some i
feel like you got some peeping toms next
door maybe
i mean if i got peeping times they they
need us enjoy the show
enjoy the show people are making
millions of dollars on that let's run
that back
you starting at only fans um so i do
that
there's something that i always do no
matter where i'm at whether i'm
a bit nervous apprehensive or just i'm
feeling myself
i say i say this i want you to repeat it
to yourselves well i say i'm
mfn mike johnson right so you would say
i'm
mf in your name and that i say it under
my breath
and that just makes me feel like no one
can stop
no no no one can stop me at all and then
i'll do uh
every single day like multiple times
throughout the day oh let's do that one
two three
i love that okay so where
do you see yourself in five years do you
think this is going to be your only book
do you think you're going to publish
another book what's next for you no in
five years
i definitely have my lady
[Music]
i i will be on my my second book will be
about to be released
my second book i already have the title
for it oh it is
i am working on two other media streams
of
loving yourself and letting go of
insecurities and so they're going to be
pretty dope in other
avenues and i'm going to be
top three uh keynote speakers in america
i love this vision and i love you're
definitely going to get there
do you manifest your your goals
absolutely
do you write them down or do you do you
visualize them how do you manifest
uh it started off when i was in height
no it started off when i was about to
join the military
because i couldn't run for crap and you
know you got to like pass tests and
stuff
and so i would write my goals down
manifest them
on the bathroom mirror on the uh on my
in my car on like the where you your
corn bumps that thing right there
in the middle of the car and then on the
microwave those are three things i see
every single day right
that's great i'll i'll put them there um
now i have three blackboards that i look
that are right there in front of my bed
and i look at them and read them every
single day
we love that because christine and i
actually we made a vision board um in
the beginning of 2020. i mean obviously
it didn't really turn out the way
i wanted none of my visions came true
nothing came true
but we're like this is a peculiar year
you know yeah yeah yeah we were really
adamant about like finding boyfriends
and getting a great job and all this
stuff happening but yeah
yeah we're stuck in our house well thank
you i feel right
thank you i'm gonna say something oh
yeah go for it if i can um so i throw a
vision board party every year
uh it's pretty dope i don't think no one
has even heard of a vision board party
right
that's our brain it's like a grown and
sexy event you know come out
i have all the magazines i have
everything there
and then the goal is for you to meet
somebody to become friends with
and like they're kind of like an
accountability buddy and then like six
months later
you know i'll bring everybody back in
you know you might bring a plus one
and we uh we talk about the old vision
board see where we are on that
[Music]
and it's just like it bridges people
together so i think i love well i love
that y'all do that
yeah but i really it's beautiful because
i know i did that with my sister and i
did it with two other
friends and it kind of was a really nice
meditative bonding moment
and it kind of put into perspective even
if nothing really came true at this
moment
it showed you what you really truly want
now or what you want in the future and
so it actually is pretty inspiring so i
think that isn't a
beautiful way to get people together and
the only party i'm trying to pre-game
for is the vision party
so let's go let's go well thank you so
much mike for coming on make sure you
guys pick up
his book making the love you want out
october
2nd you will not regret it you will not
regret it thank you so much thank you
thank you
green chef is a usda certified organic
company that makes eating well
easy and affordable with plants to fit
every kind of lifestyle
meal plans include paleo plant-powered
keto and balanced living
it's easy to eat well and discover new
recipes every week that you'll
love to cook they literally do the meal
planning grocery shopping and most of
the prep
for you week after week not to mention
the ingredients also come
pre-measured perfectly portioned and
mostly prepped
sophia and i love to blast music in the
kitchen and whip us up a delicious meal
knowing that what we are putting in our
body is high
quality ingredients so if you want to
get in on this deal
be sure to use code unwaxed80 to get 80
off your first month plus free shipping
on your first box
go to greenchef.com unwaxed80
to redeem and for more details that's
code unwaxed80 to get 80
off your first month plus free shipping
on your first box so make sure you guys
go
to greenchef.com unwaxed80
to redeem and get more details there
okay so appeared on season 23 bachelor
colton season
and season six in bachelor in paradise
i'm already in love with this girl she
is so bubbly so kind
so confident 25 from texas this is demi
hello honestly i've actually right off
the bat you are so
fun like you're so open you're so cut
out you're so yeah because we only know
you from tv so we've only seen you from
the show and the fact that you were
exactly that in person just makes my
heart so happy oh my god
thank you you know what the best part i
was just saying i wanted to bring this
up and this is now making me love you
more
is i saw that you were on wwe yes
we love wwe no way oh obsessed no
we actually talked about this in the
episode how we were like obsessed the
undertaker
triple h like growing up that was our
thing i love it too
you were literally getting escorted out
with like a chicken wing or chicken leg
or whatever
wait can you tell your storyline a
little bit um so
i've always been like a huge fan of wwe
i haven't watched it very much in the
past couple years just because i've been
so busy with
like bachelor stuff and i haven't been
able to keep up as much as i used to
but uh even on my abc bio it says like
on the bottom of it it's like is a huge
fan of the wwe
shut up and so i got awesome i got an
instagram dm that i didn't even see but
they also emailed me and my agent saw it
and he was like hey
are you interested in doing wwe blah
blah blah and i was like
hell yes are you kidding me i've always
wanted to do that
and so the i've been on it now for like
maybe the past month
and it's been like me just kind of
backstage like doing little things right
and then this week they moved to an
actual arena so they were at that yeah
they're at the thunderdome that's
awesome
and i got to walk down the ramp and like
do like
i always imagine walking down the ramp
to my own like by myself but still like
i was like walking out with some dude
yeah and i was like oh my god this is
insane wait how is this set up now
because i saw that they're doing like
the virtual
it's a zoom
no it you see all the people it looks
like a giant zoom call it's the weirdest
thing
it's crazy because i didn't know how
they were doing that because i saw that
some
soccer games and basketball games i'm
like yeah they're doing it with like a
lot of different sports now and it looks
it looks so crazy like i remember i was
like in my room and there was like a net
over like the outgoing of my room like
the balcony kind of of the room i was in
that looked
into the arena and i saw all these
things and i was like
are those people out there and then i
like peeks my head out and i was like oh
my god no those are like zoom callers
that's so awesome we should join the
next zoom call out
we're doing it next time if you're on it
we're going to kill them and be like hey
it
was so incredible i was so nervous i was
like oh my gosh i'm walking out on the
ramp
we've been that's a big deal was that
entrance
scarier for you than walking out of the
limo in the bachelor
no no way because like i had at least
had some experience at this point to
like
really nerve-wracking situations where i
could just be like put the nerves away
and just like do it it's not a big deal
right whereas whenever i got the limo i
like blacked out
i don't blame you i mean we've done
things where we had to like walk on a
runway i just and i'm not a model or
anything and you just block and you
don't remember
anything that entire minute that it
happened and they're like did i
screw up i'm not really shy i always ask
someone i'm like did i [ __ ] that up for
everyone
you're like i'm not gonna see this till
much later so if i did like
[ __ ] me then i have to redeem myself so
we're not just saying this to blow smoke
up your ass
but please blow smoke okay we got it
but you really were our favorite to
watch on colton season because you were
so
real and authentic and just 100 demi
which was so much fun because i feel
like you know it's so easy when you go
on a reality tv show that people alter
who they are just for
stage appearance or blah blah whatever
so
i mean we can get into a little bit
about like your current relationship
status but that's not really what i
wanted to talk to you about
so what did you want to sign up for the
show um i think i was just like wine
drunk one night and i just was watching
it with my friend and i just applied and
i never thought anything of it
and then i randomly got the call like i
was at work when i got this call and it
was from an la number and i was like i
have no idea who this could be but it's
from la i am answering it because i'm
from like a small little piece
why not yeah i was like this has to be
something good and it was the bachelor
people and i walked in and i was like
y'all won't believe what just happened
so you get the call what does the
audition process look like for the show
um so i got the call and then they had
me do a uh they had me send in more
photos
and fill out a huge application and then
a video so i made a video and
the video was a bunch of like random
clips that i like put together and it
was really stupid
but the best part about it was that i
somehow ruined the audio i don't know
how i did it
no so the whole time i'm talking like
this
no i'm like well my name is jimmy oh
my god and i just sent it to them and i
said sorry i can't fix it
there's like she has such a sexy deep
voice
i was like hopefully uh there's an audio
guy on set that can like fix this audio
because i have no idea what i did wrong
um and then after that uh i got called
to like a casting call in dallas so i
went there
they called me into a room it was like
my first interview they like mic you up
they have a camera and a couple people
sitting there and you
they basically like ask you a few
questions and i was like i'mma lay it
all out there
they're right and so i laid it all out
there for them
and i walked out of the room they were
like thank you we'll let you know if you
want to move forward
walked out of the room i'm halfway down
the hallway they come busting out of the
door demi
we want to move forward with you no way
it's like a movie
just slamming open it it was incredible
i was like uh-huh i know you she's like
i knew it i knew did you know right off
the bat by being so
vulnerable and being open about who you
were and like your background and who
your personality was was going to be the
thing that was going to catch the most
yeah i kind of felt like it and also
like the fact that like my mom was in
prison at the time i was like this is
going to be great for them they're going
to run with this were you worried about
that at all or were you just very much
this is who i am and people are going to
relate to this or definitely worried
about it because i didn't want to
uh like i whenever my mom called me i
was like hey like i'm doing the bachelor
like early some like in the casting
process
and i want to know if you're okay with
me talking about your situation and
stuff like that and she was cool with
everything
but it's still it's like i don't know
kind of embarrassing and stuff but
i know there are some things that i mean
i definitely even just starting this
podcast like i'm reserved to talk
about and i'm like i don't know if i
want people to know this but at the same
time it's like
this is who i am and it could be
embarrassing and it could be kind of
goofy but there's going to be that
person out there that's going you know
what
thank god for her being like that
because now i can feel like i can do
that and
so it's just one of those things where
you have to get comfortable with
yourself and kind of
you know not give a [ __ ] because
honestly at the end of the day like no
one really
cares as much as you care about it like
everyone has their own lives going on
too and that's exactly
what you did on the show was not give a
[ __ ] and that
i love that attitude i think we could
definitely take a page out of your book
and the fact that you did that
definitely shut like pissed the other
girls off
um but you didn't let their side
comments i loved it
their side comments get under your skin
you kind of just like dusted it off your
shoulder so
speaking about you pulling colton inside
and just like the whole episode of
like i think it's kind of a whole thing
of you have to get to know someone flirt
with someone do you have any
flirting techniques or tricks that you
used to do on the show or just now in
general that that work
that work because i know cindy and i
were teach me everything you know
um flirting techniques uh
you just like you know you tilt your
chin down and you give them like these
big eyes do it in the camera
oh my god she's so cute i want to go out
with you
and then you look away see that's it
like you look back again and you like do
the same thing sometimes they do a
little
like tongue out everyone at home is
[ __ ] their pants right now are you
kidding me
yeah you just have to play it like guys
are dumb okay it's an
energy thing though it is you have to
give off this thing like
i don't need you i might want you but
you guys
love confident girls they do i have
found that
no guy wants to be with an insecure girl
so i'm all about faking it till i make
it because i'm
you know not 100 confident so do you
find that when you're
dating someone that confidence helps you
or hurts you sometimes
um i think that confidence
always pretty much helps me um
sometimes it can be overbearing but i
don't think that people
like receive it that way like if i think
all humans are attracted to confidence
because it's like
like i dated somebody who was a piece of
[ __ ] person but
i was so interested in them and
continued to be because they were just
so confident in who they were
and they were just like owning
everything they did even if it was the
stupidest [ __ ] in the world like they
still were just owning it and i was like
god i love that i love that somebody is
not phased
and worried about what other people are
going to think they're just going to do
whatever they want to do
yeah and that's what we all kind of like
want to have we all want to be
that person who just does whatever we
want to do so i think confidence is
definitely more attractive it's a plus
because i feel like a lot of guys that
sometimes with confidence they can get
intimidated by it because maybe they
just don't have enough confidence
themselves but i definitely can see
where
i've gone out with guys where i'm like i
you may be like probably the worst
person i think that there's different
types of confidence you know there's
like a sexual confidence there's a
confidence in your job with career what
you do there's confidence in
you know the way you walk so what would
you describe
your confidence as um definitely
a sexual confidence like i know that i'm
like
i'm very confident with my like
sexuality and like
you know sex life like i'm very good at
all of that
like i won't we're going to need to talk
about this we'll put some people on
their hands and knees back and forth
there we go
but by the way you don't even need to if
you yourself don't believe you are like
that
thinking that and acting like that
really does help the whole
way yeah like if you are insecure about
like you know yourself like in the
bedroom and like having sex with
somebody or something
if you're insecure about it you're going
to underperform and then you're gonna
like it's gonna make it worse and worse
and like your head like being in your
head
if you're like i'm a bad [ __ ] and i'm
going to
ride this or i'm going to be the hottest
woman
in the bedroom they've ever seen if you
just tell yourself that
enough times you'll believe it and then
all of a sudden next thing you know
they're like oh my god that was the
greatest sex in my life and i've had
some really good advice
i've had so many of my girlfriends say
when they're in the bedroom like oh i
don't
i think too much about like i want to
look hot i want to feel like
think they think i'm hot but then you
realize it's not enjoyable for you it's
really probably not enjoyable for them
because once you
actually believe this is hot i feel high
i'm sexy i'm confident
then the experience is going to be 10
times better but people don't understand
that it's like you don't have to
you don't have to perform for this
person it's like perform for yourself
like have them here next to you go hey
yes exactly you have to tell yourself
like this is about me
like this is about how i'm feeling
during this and like i'm gonna be as
nasty as i want and i'm gonna feel as
good as i wanna feel
and then you actually start enjoying it
instead of just like faking orgasms and
pretending like it's fun and just
feeling insecure the whole then you're
going to condition yourself to actually
believe that like you can't get an
orgasm or you can't do that well in the
bedroom it's like you have to actually
want it believe it and then it actually
will come and the guy will
make sure the guy is actually doing it
for you it was a girl like who what what
would you say like speaking of
relationships what would you say are
signs where you should
probably get out because i know there's
a lot of girls that probably or guys
that go out these people that they're
kind of toxic or there's little things
that they do here and there that aren't
probably benefiting from you and they
could either be like a momentary thing
where they're going through something or
the difference of it actually being a
problem like what would you say that the
small things that you've noticed where
you should probably move on i i think
that
a lot of it comes from the gut feeling
the intuition i feel like women's
intuition is very on point
a hundred percent because every time
i've ever had an
inkling that something was up something
has always been up every time
every time every time so i think you
listen to your gut because your
instincts know
and also there's definitely signs like
if your
partner is liking a bunch of like hot
half naked
women on instagram that something's up
like that's that's not cool like they
don't know them they're flirting with
them essentially
so like that's a big red flag um
especially if you bring
up a problem that you have to the
partner and the partner makes you feel
like an idiot
and doesn't make you feel reassured
because if
i like you know whenever i'm loyal to
someone and
i love somebody and they have a problem
with something
i'm here to make them feel so reassured
i'm like oh my gosh i'm so
sorry like let me clear the air like i'm
i will fix whatever you need me to fix
like
i want you to be comfortable yeah so if
i'm not getting that return
i'm like something's up yeah but mainly
that intuition that gut feeling like
we know women know women always know
you know maybe they don't never know but
even when you tell you your friends are
telling you like you need to get out of
this and you know
deep in your core this person is not
well it's so much easier said than done
you know it is
we never love love is blind love is
blind and i'm so bad at practicing what
i preach
oh me too you know me too for sure we're
talking about having all this confidence
but definitely we have our off days
where we're definitely
not being the person we want to be
especially with the guy or girl we're
going out with or
with our friends or like with ourselves
i mean we're human we're not one thing
like yeah we're not we're not
one-dimensional there's there's days
that go up and down and i think that
that's kind of the point of like i like
having my off days though because it
kind of reminds me okay like i've had
that [ __ ] time i'm learning something
from this
yeah and i can move forward with and i
can grow from the next relationship or
like now i know what i actually
want for myself and others yeah yeah
it's like
you know you have days where you're like
i'm a bad [ __ ] and then i have a day
where i'm like i'm a sad [ __ ]
yes and then i'm like okay next day
tomorrow i'm going to be a bad [ __ ]
again
well do you want to put your plug where
people can find you yes so you can find
me on instagram at
demi underscore not underscore lovato
and then on twitter at demi underscore
burnett
and my podcast is called big demi energy
and you should definitely check it out
because it's
pretty much a lot like this talk right
here perfect yeah we're gonna continue
the conversation on
her show from all of us here at the show
thanks for staying unwaxed
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at unwaxed podcast
your producer is will sterling we'll see
you next week